[Musique]
bulls et la ligne éditoriale du journal
charlie hebdo et la provocation et la
transgression et une fois encore en
pleine crise du coronavirus
l'hebdomadaire satirique a frappé fort
avec une une qui ne laisse personne
indifférente sur ce dessin de félipe on
peut découvrir un jeune homme
visiblement entre la vie et la mort avec
l'indication le pack 2020 s'adapte
accompagné de deux flèches l'une vers un
électrocardiogramme avec l'indication
épreuves écrites l'autre vers un tube
respiratoire avec l'inscription épreuves
orales une couverture qui encore une
fois pour but de choquer et c'est une
fois encore une réussite si certains ont
salué le fait de rire de tout plusieurs
internautes ont moins apprécié la
démarche dure pas sûr que les parents
qui ont perdu ou vont perdre un enfant
apprécié cette couverture
je suis pour la liberté d'expression
bien sûr mais il n'empêche que je trouve
certaines caricatures de charlie hebdo
irrespectueuse et vous que pensez vous
de cette une de charlie hebdo
[Musique]
alors il ya quelqu'un qui me dit on
jours on voit la touffe de lio j'appelle
le csa allait la couverture de charlie
hebdo choquer ou pas choqué il ya plein
de gens qui dit mon dieu c'est horrible
c'est pas drôle vous méritez une
protides pour une procédure
pas sûr que les perdants voilà qui ont
perdu leurs enfants puissent rigoler à
cela maxime kenny qu'est ce t'en penses
on se trouve que la une les ni choquant
ni drôle et ne pas s'attendre à mieux
elle dénonce rien elle est tiède
elle a pas de goût elle sert à rien plus
y ait même pas d'opinion tranchée y'a
pas d'angle c'est plus ce que c'était
franchement merci
barroso dans le juste
si justement à la un angle à l'a1 sens
et c'est effectivement dans la dette de
la 2 du journal mais effectivement ça
n'est pas drôle ça fait des mois et des
mois on en parle à sotchi ça n'est
jamais drôle
effectivement on sait même pas que c'est
c'est pas pour choquer oui c'est le but
de ce journal effectivement c'était de
déranger la sépaq ça dérange c'est que
ça ne laisse indifférent et en plus
c'est pas drôle donc ça n'a aucun
intérêt et malheureusement depuis des
mois effectivement il ya eu un mouvement
et on sait que le drame qu'ils ont vécu
effectivement on est tous allés à eux
mais là depuis des mois ça ne sert à
rien et c'est un bad romance est nul et
voilà peut être on peut être derrière
eux et dire qu'ils sont jamais drôle
j'ai avec eux je savais que c'est pas
drôle ça fait six mois qu'ils sont
drôles
là c'est très difficile de critiquer
charlet vu effectivement vécu mais mais
moi non je suis choqué par cette une
je sais au delà même du fait que la
trouve pas drôle du tout
je suis choqué par ce que charlie c'est
plus que d'autres encore partie du
paysage citoyens de la france charlie et
d'os internet la france et là je trouve
qu'ils se moquent des victimes
il ironise sur un drame national c'est
pas à eux c'est pas drôle et c'est pas
donc je suis extrêmement choqué et
extrêmement peiné pour eux ça choquerait
beaucoup beaucoup de monde rené rené
malleville c'est à dire que moi je lis
charlie hebdo et away je détruis ge
oui pourquoi je le lis comme le canard
enchaîné je lis pas mal la donne
c'est le canard enchaîné c'est bien oui
et non mais j'avais dit emma sinon je le
vire pas mais là il m'a tellement
habitués charia hebdo à d une petit peu
moins que la wii
oui je reconnais que c'est un peu comme
le cas de toulouse qui se voit que alors
que franchement oui mais quand tous les
trois mois oui mais non mais voici mai
date où il roule moi je vois ça je dis
pas amputer je suis choqué je vais
mourir non mais oui je trouve que c'est
maladroit série noire oui oui mathieu je
te dire moi je vais te dire d'abord s'il
se passe à lille alors ils me font très
très bon jamais fait rire mais au-delà
de ça j'en ai marre de deux de ces
jeunes gens qui en france se prétend de
provocateurs font bouger les choses
allaient les stéphane guillon sur france
inter
les charlie hebdo mais les gars ceux qui
ont vraiment des couilles et tout mon
respect c'est ceux qui s'opposent dans
un état en chine en corée en russie et
ceux qui osent qui talent plus rien pas
mourir ceux qui osent y aller mais en
france en france
oser dire wager découle je vais
provoquer les choses après la zone pays
le plus le plus le plus libertaire
possible qui va rien t'arriver
voilà c est en plus charlie pardon moi
je ne suis pas charlie se trouve qu'ils
se sont des gens dangereux voilà nom est
bon sens à votre avis
tu vas trop loin l'asie c'est l'avis de
mathieu c'est là du jeu mathieu ginès et
le donner son avis blessé le dos de son
avis il a le droit de le donner son avis
mathieu oui donc voilà il dit ce qu'il
pense 500 cadres comme ça n'engage que
lui vous avez jusqu'au bout rosati
matthew booth et que la première fois
qu'ils ont fait l'an une et on sait
lorsque les attentats évidemment ça a
été horrible ce qui s'est passé c'était
très triste mais quand ils ont refaire
ensuite pour provoquer une autre une
dessus alors qu'on avait vu ce qui
s'était passé pour moi c'était une honte
donc voilà encore une fois ces gens là
pardon je trouve qu'ils sont dangereux
donc il faut arrêter maintenant
es tu encore une fois tous ces
humoristes qui se prétendent mettre des
coups de pied dans la fourmilière et qui
se prennent pour des des grandes che
guevara alors qu'ils sont dans un pays
où par dont une à rien t'arriver
voilà cela fermez la et puis et puis et
puis draghi maintenant les géraldine
maillet pour les jeunes j'étais obligé
les gens à mathieu il est épaulé gilet
jaune que j'étais pour l'équipe qui est
pour les gens qui est qui et qui souffre
au run et qui est contre les gens qui se
souvient chez année sa neuvième pole et
il était pour les généraux et brillant
mathieu a souvent défendu chez doux
giraldi nature mais tu te rends compte
de ce que tu dit à dire que tim hockey
la première les premières caricatures
théâtreux d'après en haut ils l'ont bien
cherché
d'ailleurs j'ai parlé nous de chercher
je peux je vais chercher l'origine il y
aurait pas lieu de dire comment ils ont
osé leur sert de l'irb et leur faible il
n'aurait pas dû
on a le droit de faire ce qu'on veut on
est dans une année dans une démocratie
que l'on a le droit de caricaturer ce
qu'on me raconte j'avais dit la première
fois la première fois j'avais mauvais
mais non non géraldine jeune fille dont
j'attendais attendez attendez s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît aux cadres de huit
mois moi ce que je veux dire mine de
rien on a on est dans un pays on a la
chance d'être dans un pays ne peut
caricaturer on peut se moquer retire on
peut se moquer de tout des religions on
peut se passer de la politique on peut
se moquer et faire de la satire ça c'est
une chance incroyable
après la question voudra se poser c'est
est ce que ça vous fait rire ou pas moi
mais voilà nous dire par exemple moi je
suis je suis charny et je les défendrai
toujours mais ne me font pas rire du
tout voilà ça n'est pas mon humour mais
ça n'est pas mon amour c'est peut-être
que je suis peut-être que c'est moi tu
sais mais il paie moi ce peut être s'il
ya des gens que ça fait rire moi ça me
fait pas rire moi c'est tout je suis
imperméable à sept jours voilà moi yade
il ya des humoristes font énormément
rire que j'adore et à des humoristes
même que j'adore et qui ne font pas rien
voilà avec shadow du monde on peut
comprendre les gens qui aiment bien mais
moi j'ai pas dit qui me faisait rire
d'accord oui comment tu es comme on dit
que j'ai été maladroit mais thomas
mathieu ara te le dire on est pas
content que terme et la part de cabanes
de madame servir moi ma part a quand
même triste le bénin n'est pas toi il
parlait patois départ n'était pas
humoriste était pas sur france 5 arte
sur radio star qu'on admire ça n'a rien
à voir
oui / non géré a dit jalal injuste de
plus important d'être nique de le faire
c'est de l'humour trash ou
irrévérencieux politiquement fou bien
sûr qu'elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
allée à droite est le plus important
il a vu que je n'ai jamais chanté je
prends un but il est assez pour la ville
d'avoir le droit de le faire quelles que
soient les conditions et dur sur un
point virgule
oui mais en même temps est-ce que j'ai
le cuir non moi je vous rejoins bonjour
effecté je comprends ce que dit mathieu
et je comprends géraldine mais
effectivement cheryl l'hebdo ont été
effectivement quoi qu'il fasse quoi
qu'il dise effectivement bien il ya un
passé après au moins le dire ça n'est
pas drôle et ce qui les tuera
à terme c'est qu'effectivement il se il
faut souvent et il faut des mauvaises
une et ça n'est pas réussi moi je vois
très bien - et c'est une et je vous dis
un truc très perso a à peine morte
d'éminents human en mer avec son cadavre
et montant qui disait un montant
président et avec un verre qui
souhaitent organiser et moi je suis de
l'intérieur c'était très dur on a fait
un procès et on a perdu ça n'était
peut-être pas drôle mais je vais droit
de le faire moi je comprends très bien
que ça ne passe pas rire mais laissons
1,27 eric 2 voilà humoristique faire son
travail après
on rit pas peu importe ne peut pas les
on peut pas les connaître on n'a pas
droit de le faire
mathieu même si c'est dérangeant tu as
raison c'est dérangeant mais à l'époque
quelle vie aux mots dans quel monde on
vit à ce moment là mais sont les jeunes
et tout ce que j'ai fait ce que je peux
dire des animaux bras du match et pas
mal content de me faire insulter ce que
je questionnement évidemment bien
britannique robin oui et pas le faisait
notamment que c'est bien la liberté est
évidemment que c'était très très bien
qu'ils se permettent des choses qu'ils
dénoncent comme ils n'ont pas la
première fois
lorsqu'on et les attentes a fini
seulement qu'une fois qu'ils ont vu les
catastrophes que ce avait eu en
conséquence sur plein de gens innocents
je trouve que je trouve c'est mon avis
le faire une deuxième fois c'était
vraiment de l'amener en vocations ils
sont dans la risle dommages collatéraux
dans l'écho les dommages n'ont pas été
comme la loco est grand que dans la rue
et des dommages collatéraux s'engager
d'autres personnes aussi pardon de
pouvoir dire ça aussi ça regarde j'ai
d'autres personnes et je trouve que
c'est en ça que je trouve que c'était
totalement irresponsable voilà alors mon
avis que ce qu'ils veulent c'est non
mais si je peux me permettre mathieu
lalala l'acheteur tech pas du tout votre
avis bien entendu parce que fo dit ça
voudrait dire qu'on n'a pas le droit de
faire ce qu'on veut et ce qu'on appelle
un doigt la satire à l'humour et donc ça
c'est ça c'est pas possible on peut pas
dire s'agit de verlaine
oui la supérette avec mathieu parce que
qu' il n'y a aucun frein possible à la
liberté de la presse parce que sinon toi
tu seras choqué par quelque chose avec
ta sensibilité mois par autre chose donc
à ce moment là on va mettre des freins
ça s'appelle de la censure donc il n'y a
aucun sens en revanche je partage tout à
fait l'avis de cyril sur le fait que
c'est leur rendre service parce que moi
aussi j'ai toujours été charlie est plus
que jamais de les critiquer éditorial
nommée marie conserve ya plein de gens
qui nous disent vous avez dit à un
moment vous n'avez pas être n'étiez pas
charlie et que vous condamniez bien sûr
les agents terroristes non non non non
non non mais attendez moi je vais vous
dire moi charlie hebdo
voilà on est et charlie tous au moment
même où ça s'est passé parce qu'on
combatte et les actes terroristes
maintenant dans la vie de tous les jours
- charlie hebdo je ne l'achète jamais ça
fait pas rire du tout vraiment il se
trouve ça et je trouve si je trouve le
journal
voilà dit la vérité je trouve que c'est
un torchon mais voilà je me dis là
mais bon mais on est on est on est on
sait qu'en version ou on est contre les
actes terroristes
on était dans la rue pour charlie hebdo
mais c'est pas pour charlie hebdo et
c'est surtout pour la liberté
d'expression qu'on est taillée dans la
rue cyrille une série complète riche
avec des unes très dur la chanson est
pour autant à aucun moment où j'ai dit
je vais interdire cette huile mais
france cherche à l'hommage
je suis d'accord c'est un hommage qui
m'ont fait j'en ai fait trois chapes sur
moi à la limite ça fait plaisir à ma
mère
voilà insulter les gens s'aménage une
série non non mais c'est un hommage
parce que bon et puis on va pas se
mentir les chéris voilà maintenant on se
dit les choses
charlie hebdo là on ne parle pas de tout
ce qui s'est passé forcément on parle de
la rue nous parlent de leur travail
voilà leur travail il pleut ou il plaît
pas et il ya beaucoup de gens regardent
et sûre sur les voilà je vous le dis sur
les réseaux sociaux ya plein de gens qui
disent les une de charlie hebdo font
rire qui franchement quelle honte
charlie hebdo
un peu de respect pour les défunts et
leur famille sheikh les besoins ses
sourires c'est de la provocation c'est
dommage mais ça n'empêche pas ces gens
là bien sûr d'être contre les actes
qu'héroïne c'est sûr et c'est nation
voilà mercredi aussi un jeu jouer bas
c'est ce que tu dit mathieu exactement
mais je suis sûr qu'on ait terrorisme à
pardon banon aura bien sûr et c'est ce
que dit rené aussi vous êtes vous êtes
d'accord sur un point haut des allées on
va regarder ce qui se dit si les
téléspectateurs qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent qu'ils ont été choqués ou pas
choquer oui choqué voyons pas or voilà
irrespectueuse pour les familles de
victimes oui à 71% donc une très large
majorité